[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález ecuador e
inaugura el calendario electoral del
2021 en américa latina' con unas
elecciones presidenciales marcadas por
las dificultades económicas la pandemia
de kobe 19 e incertidumbre ciudadana
cerca de 13 millones de ecuatorianos
están llamados a las urnas para
participar en unos comicios con un
número inédito de candidatos 16 binomios
se juegan entonces la silla presidencial
en el palacio de carondelet este número
de candidatos no tiene precedentes en la
historia democrática de ecuador pero
ecuador se juega también un cambio
importante y es mantener la tendencia
del socialismo del siglo 21 que fue
establecido durante el gobierno del ex
presidente rafael correa o terminar de
desligarse de esta tendencia política
tal y como lo ha intentado hacer el
mandatario saliente
lenin moreno de quien también haremos
balance de su gestión en el siguiente
informe los ponemos en contexto en torno
a la situación que está viviendo ecuador
de cara a las elecciones presidenciales
'ecuador revive la nostalgia en las
calles antes de las elecciones generales
del 7 de febrero el recuerdo de rafael
correa- aún está presente en algunos
ciudadanos que clavan la vuelta al
socialismo
andrés heras representa la tendencia a
fin el expresidente correa un economista
de 35 años que implante a un programa de
ayuda social con la entrega de mil
dólares a un millón de familias
ecuatorianas ante la pérdida del 40% de
los ingresos a causa de la pandemia
[Música]
cuando una crisis económica sin
precedente de la que culpan al actual
presidente lenin moreno y demandan
volver al viejo modelo político
igual que él
porque se trabaja con el señor
que se ha asesorado por el señor correa
porque si fue un señor hay muchas
personas que están tratando de después
de esta pandemia recuperar lo que es el
comercio entonces sí sería muy bueno que
les ayude para así poder fomentar otra
vez lo que es su capital su ingreso para
seguir pues en el día a día
del otro lado de la acera el programa
social de andrés araus es cuestionado
por su principal contendor el candidato
de derecha y banquero guillermo lasso es
una propuesta en el aire hueca con
dinero que no le pertenece al gobierno
ese dinero del banco central le
pertenece a los depositantes de la banca
a las a los municipios a las prefecturas
y al sistema de seguridad social del
ecuador por lo tanto ese no es un dinero
de propiedad del gobierno el actual
presidente del inh moreno también se
presentó como partidario de rafael
correa antes de su giro político
que con andrés araujo aseguran no
repetirán
para analizar este tema hemos invitado
al programa a maría paz services ella es
decana de la facultad de ciencias
sociales y jurídicas de la uis y se une
a esta conversación desde la ciudad de
quito la capital ecuatoriana allí
también se encuentra nuestro siguiente
invitado simón pachano él es doctor en
ciencia política también es docente de
esa misma asignatura en flacso en
ecuador les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación de este
debate pueden dejar las preguntas y
también los comentarios en las redes
sociales en la recuerdo estamos en
facebook también o se encuentra en
instagram y en twitter como france24
sant y luego mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
puntocom mediante el departamento
internet que en instagram están haciendo
en este momento una encuesta para que
ustedes dejen allí sus comentarios y
participen activamente en este debate
pues ya tenemos el tema tenemos el
contexto y tenemos los invitados
comienzo entonces por mariah pasa allí
en la ciudad de quito gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en el debate maría paz
y lo que uno ve a simple vista fuera de
las fronteras de ecuador es que este
país suramericano está fuertemente
polarizado y muy dividido para estas
elecciones presidenciales que tan
dividido esta ecuador para estos
comicios maría paz
buenas noches santiago buenas noches
desde a quienes nos escuchen y saludos
sobre todo a simón es un gusto para mí
compartir este espacio con él y con
ustedes qué tan / super dividido no
sabremos definitivamente hasta el
próximo domingo y creo que es justamente
muestra de ello es dos elementos que voy
a señalar por un lado que todavía en
esta elección seguimos en el debate del
correísmo y el anti correísmo es decir
no podemos negar que al margen de crisis
económica de pandemia en la oposición o
varios todos esos sectores que pretenden
hacer oposición una logo particular una
propuesta que nos desmarque del debate
público del proyecto correísta de rafael
correa y del resto de proyectos
políticos y por otro lado el otro
elemento que creo que evidencia la
polarización es que tenemos 16
candidatos en la papeleta
es difícil de entender ese es el
panorama político simón cuando uno ve 16
candidatos 16 binomios para para aspirar
a la presidencia de la vicepresidencia
en simón de este país donde poco más de
13 millones de personas están convocadas
esto es un mal síntoma a nivel político
tener tantos partidos y tan fragmentada
la el espectro político en el país
y gracias por la invitación santiago un
gusto estar como mariah paso un saludo a
la audiencia si efectivamente es un mal
síntoma un síntoma de un de una crisis
muy profunda del sistema político
ecuatoriano que viene saliendo de un
modelo digamos así muy concentrado en
términos políticos que fue el de los 10
años de los gobiernos de rafael correa
donde prácticamente la única figura
política era el presidente y lograba
además una mayoría absoluta en la
asamblea nacional y un control
prácticamente de todos los poderes del
estado
esto se terminó con el gobierno
de lenin moreno a pesar de que fue
elegido por su misma digamos su misma
tendencia política
pero tampoco fue capaz el gobierno de
lenin moreno por su debilidad y por una
serie de otras razones que podemos ir
conversando las de lograr que digamos
desarmar todo el modelo que se había
implantado y tener un sistema político
competitivo democrático no que es lo que
se buscaría realmente y lo que tenemos
ahora entonces es la búsqueda de un
nuevo modelo no solamente económico sino
político y están enfrentados en ese
sentido las dos
y candidaturas que ustedes ya han
resaltado tanto en las noticias
anteriores como en el producción y
tenemos entonces una polarización muy
fuerte la polarización es tanto en el
correísmo anti correísmo como en lo
económico que se ha señalado también
maria paz teniendo claro entonces que la
gran disputa acá ya lo mencionaba al
principio es este modelo económico y
este modelo político ecuador pues
necesita una ayuda un impulso económico
por la pandemia por el antecedente que
se vaya cargando desde hace algunos años
pero entonces a la luz de ese panorama
maría paz que tanta división de poderes
hay con las instituciones que tanto
podemos creer en las instituciones
electorales para estos comicios del
próximo fin de semana
pero complejísima la pregunta y la
respuesta también va a ser compleja
porque por un lado tenemos un país que
como bien señala simón esta crisis de
partidos políticos no es algo antojadizo
brutal o coyuntural es algo que deriva
de un proceso largo y a partir de ahí en
las instituciones es justamente el gran
talón de aquiles de esta democracia
débil o cierto sin embargo yo creo que
podríamos aspirar a que el día domingo
las cosas transcurran con la mayor
normalidad es decir creo que todo si la
opinión pública internacional recordara
también el desatino que fueron el
proceso electoral pasado lo cierto en
que se demoraron días en salir las los
resultados teníamos un gobierno muy
fuerte a diferencia de lo que tenemos
ahora que es un gobierno políticamente
muy débil sin embargo también durante el
gobierno del ex presidente correa había
un control absoluto de todos los poderes
del estado ahora hay muchas pugnas por
supuesto pero me atrevería a decir que
para la democracia es anna la pugna
porque al menos estamos viviendo la
diferencia cuando se contraponen
posiciones de las distintas
instituciones que no son perfectas que
adolecen de muchos problemas
pero al menos hay contrariedad en las
posturas mientras que vivimos al menos
durante diez años un sistema electoral
que estaba adoptado por el ejecutivo un
sistema legislativo optado por el
ejecutivo un poder judicial optado por
el ejecutivo una sociedad civil optado
por el ejecutivo y así podría seguir con
los ejemplos con lo cual las elecciones
a pesar de la pandemia a pesar de la
situación económica terrible que vive el
ecuador fruto de esos desgobierno y de
varios otros factores a pesar de que
tenemos un gobierno muy débil ahorita
que termina su periodo con muchísimas
complejidades creo yo que está diseñado
y que aborda a tener transparencia en
los resultados y es así como debemos
pensarlo desde la ciudadanía y es así
como debemos observar simón su opinión
al respecto sobre esta independencia de
las instituciones de cara a estos
comicios electorales y para la siguiente
ronda sigo con usted
él
el problema con las instituciones
electorales es bastante serio porque
también venimos saliendo de un modelo de
gestión que era el de un consejo
electoral surgido de un proceso de
concurso que en realidad fue cooptado
por un solo partido político y volvimos
después de una reforma constitucional de
una reforma legal hecha por a partir de
una consulta popular convocada por el
presidente moreno volvimos a tener la
presencia de partidos políticos en el
consejo nacional electoral esto provocó
un debate interno conflicto interno en
el consejo que ha hecho ciertas sombras
sobre el manejo de las elecciones y por
otro lado hay un conflicto entre el
organismo el administrador de las
elecciones que es el consejo electoral y
el organismo de justicia electoral es el
tribunal contencioso electoral es decir
hemos tenido esos dos conflictos a lo
largo de esta campaña
problemas serios con la calificación de
candidaturas y con una serie de los
procedimientos necesarios para la
dirección que han ensombrecido como
decía antes de alguna manera este este
proceso esperemos que esto no sea una
justificación o una causa para impugnar
las elecciones o para echar sombras
sobre los resultados que tengamos
finalmente simón ahí uno de los
candidatos que es andrés arados del
centro democrático es claramente un
antisistema busca mantener esa fuerza
del socialismo del siglo 21 recuperar un
poco lo que construyó rafael corre a lo
largo de esa década de gobierno allí en
ecuador y ha tenido un desempeño
precisamente durante el gobierno de
rafael correa en diferentes cargos
públicos
está la sombra del correísmo muy fuerte
en ecuador estamos a la puerta a la
vuelta de la esquina de un regreso del
correísmo es muy fuerte la influencia de
rafael correa en este candidato y en el
correísmo allí en ecuador para estas
elecciones
yo creo que las imágenes que ustedes han
presentado son la mejor respuesta a esta
pregunta si ustedes se fijan en las
manifestaciones que se hacen de la
candidatura de andrés araus van a ver
que la foto predominante es la del ex
presidente correa es una foto muy grande
unos carteles grandes en donde el
candidato a rauch aparece más bien con
una foto pequeña creo que eso dice mucho
de la de la presencia de rafael correa a
mí me parece que estamos frente a una
situación muy similar a la que se dio en
argentina después del derrocamiento de
juan domingo perón cuando fue derrocado
y salió al exilio en españa él estuvo 18
años prácticamente dirigiendo o
sobrevolando por la política argentina
creo que ese es lo que ha sucedido en
menor tiempo
y rafael correa y recordemos también que
como regreso pero a la argentina cuando
sé que se ve candidatizar a héctor
cámpora para la presidencia la consigna
era cámpora al gobierno perón al poder
creo que estamos en algo muy similar en
este momento además que recordemos que
rafael correa en algún momento al inicio
de la campaña busca va a ser
precisamente la fórmula vicepresidencial
de andrés a grados y regresar a ecuador
él en este momento vive en bélgica donde
reside desde hace ya varios años su
esposa es belga y por eso reside en allí
y buscaba regresar a la escena política
ecuatoriana en la figura de
vicepresidencia pero este problema legal
que tiene en curso allí en ecuador no le
permitió asumir ese papel en la campaña
a la vicepresidencia maría para su
impresión y el balance que usted hace el
correísmo es fuerte todavía allí
claramente se nota en los ciudadanos que
extrañan estos años de bonanza petrolera
en ecuador cuando hubo una gran cantidad
de construcción en infraestructura un
avance
en las vías en los aeropuertos en la
infraestructura general en ecuador
el correísmo es fuerte definitivamente
pero como usted bien señalaba ese
correísmo el correísmo de bonanza el
correísmo que no va a poder volver aún
cuando llegara el candidato ahora
estamos todos claros que sería con la
sombra o bajo el el poder la hegemonía
del ex presidente correa pero ese
correísmo no va a pasar más allá de los
símbolos políticos discursivos que sin
duda algunas son potentes y que no
podemos menospreciar pero fue un
correísmo también cuya fortaleza fue en
una economía llegó una bonanza no vivida
en el ecuador en muchísimos años y eso
desde luego no va a volver ahora también
habría que pensar pensando un escenario
en que en que volviera en que ganará
efectivamente el candidato araus es
curioso no porque por un lado podemos
enfrentarnos a la presencia inminente
del ex presidente correa de hecho el
candidato a rauch ya ha dicho que lo
primero que va a hacer es revisar la
sentencia condenatoria es de última
instancia que no cabe revisión pero él
va a revisar va a cambiar los jueces
todos estos anuncios ha hecho pero
también no nos olvidemos el presidente
actual
el presidente de lenin moreno llegó del
brazo del
presidente correa y cuando no nos
esperábamos un viraje es decir no
podríamos anticipar ni adivinar las
cosas pero creo que ante un escenario
mucho más complejo de polarización
económica y social en el caso de que
llegue a rauch como muchas encuestas lo
señalan no sabemos cuál sería realmente
la relación de fidelidad con el ex
presidente correa y cuál sería el
capital político que él podría aglutinar
al margen de correa sólo por mencionar
un dato en la universidad de murcia
internacional sek un colega hacia una
pequeña investigación esta semana
revisando 11.800 tweets y la tendencia
es araos presidente más y el miedo más y
rafael es decir asociado a las cuentas
de rafael correa- siguen teniendo un
poder de difusión de comunicación pero
también siguen teniendo un respaldo
ciudadano
simón ya lo dice maría paz el escenario
es completamente distinto no hay una
bonanza petrolera ya no hay el dinero
suficiente para mantener esas grandes
esos grandes proyectos de
infraestructura que
y van a tener lugar allí en ecuador el
país está muy endeudado y así lo
demostró el año pasado al pedir varias
solicitudes de líneas de crédito al
fondo monetario internacional- una deuda
de casi 60 mil millones de dólares el
escenario hoy en día es muy distinto
cuáles son las necesidades primarias de
los ecuatorianos que tendrán que hacer
frente sea cual sea el presidente que
salga electo de estos comicios ahora en
febrero o en abril en una segunda vuelta
pero las necesidades son básicamente
empleo o generación de trabajo son
necesidades económicas básicas es
necesario tener un plan muy agresivo de
reducción de la pobreza tener incluso
políticas sociales que sean llamémosle
contracíclicas no en general pero yo
creo volviendo un poco a lo que dándole
continuidad a lo que decía maría paz que
estoy totalmente de acuerdo creo que un
gobierno de andrés hará un gobierno de
la tendencia de ver correísmo y requiere
de una economía expansiva digamos así
requiere de un gasto público muy alto no
puede manejarse de otra manera y por lo
tanto es muy probable que acudan a mayor
endeudamiento y a lo que ya ha anunciado
andrés araus que es el uso de la de las
reservas internacionales del banco
central
y creo que esa será una de la primera
medida que él ha anunciado pero además
de eso vamos a tener seguramente
elevación de por ejemplo el impuesto a
la salida de capitales de divisas que es
un impuesto que actualmente es del 5%
andrés ahora nos ha dicho que lo elevará
al 27% no sé de dónde sale la cifra de
27 pero que lo elevará al 27% para
evitar la salida de dólares
y hay un riesgo muy fuerte perdón antes
de eso el incrementar ese impuesto
significa
y reducir la posibilidad de que vengan
capitales externos a ecuador por el
costo que tendría no es cierto para
empresas internacionales el enviar sus
utilidades en filtrar
el otro aspecto es que él
y una de las medidas que se tomarían en
de acuerdo a las declaraciones de andrés
araus es la utilización de una especie
de dinero electrónico como le han
llamado que también funcionaría con las
reservas del banco central es decir
sería prácticamente una emisión
inorgánica de dinero y eso podría poner
en riesgo a la dolarización eso
y otra de las otras medidas de tutelar
creo que puede ser puede ser muy
riesgoso el manejo económico de una
tendencia como digo que requiere de una
economía en expansión pero que no hay
las condiciones para eso si maría para
su opinión al respecto sobre las
necesidades primarias simón menciona el
aspecto económico que más necesitan los
ecuatorianos
yo bueno desde luego el aspecto
económico que se ha vuelto una crisis de
supervivencia como pasó en el mundo
entero y en el ecuador y acabamos con
una una crisis económica no cierto pero
la que le podría añadir a una crisis de
identidad y ahí fue muy hábil el
correísmo es decir pensemos en una
sociedad que estaba absolutamente
desarticulada y vino todo este proceso
de un líder mesiánico y construyeron
lograron articular a través de un
discurso de un discurso de confrontación
una nueva identidad una nueva identidad
que quizás dos años los pocos años que
han transcurrido nos han permitido
identificar que si caló y que no escalo
sólo en la gente más humilde que tenía
una relación clientelar a través de los
bonos y de unos beneficios que caló en
una generación de jóvenes profesionales
cuyo primer empleo fue en el sector
público bajo unos salarios y unas
condiciones de muchísima bonanza y se
pide el hizo bajo discursos y bajo
dádivas
de hecho inconscientemente una
generación a una generación entera me
atrevo a decir con lo cual de los
posteriores se respira nuevamente unos
unos niveles de libertad nuevamente hay
debate se retoma y pero al mismo tiempo
está esta ligera euforia o satisfacción
dura muy poco dura muy poco por dos
elementos en primer lugar con la crisis
económica porque se rompe está esta
ficción de la bonanza una vez que sale
el correísmo y que entra a lenin moreno
y se distancia del correísmo se percibe
una sensación de justicia en la sociedad
cuando se judicial izan algunos casos y
llegan la pandemia llega la pandemia y
me estoy saltando el gran hecho
histórico de octubre de 2019 que
mostraba un poco más de la reacción de
esos sectores que quedan por fuera del
escenario es decir que se les quita el
pedazo de la torta o del pastel y
entonces yo creo que estos años además
de de este año catastrófico del cob y
que nos ha remecido a todos en los
distintos niveles encontramos un ecuador
una vez más quebrado y yo creo espero
equivocarme que es caldo de cultivo de
estos expertos y de estas maquinarias
electorales de reconstruir unas unas
identidades ficticias y capitalizar eso
y añadiría a la urgencia económica la
urgencia nuevamente de identidad
nacional en estos binomios de candidatos
prácticamente 3 que son los que tienen
la mayor intención de voto pero todo
puede pasar el domingo andrés sagrados
que ya lo estamos mencionando guillermo
lazo también que en dos ocasiones
anteriores a participaban comicios
presidenciales y yakuza cha que es un
líder indígena que ha tenido una voz y
voto en una región destacada allí en el
sur de ecuador él es de la ciudad de
cuenca o cerca cuenca y llega con un
discurso muy particular que lectura si
usted simón de este candidato que de
acuerdo a la intención de voto podría
ser el que definiría esta segunda vuelta
dependiendo de a quién le ceda su
capital político en esa segunda vuelta
sí yo creo que ya que ya q pérez recoge
una votación por un lado la votación
histórica del movimiento indígena que
normalmente se ha situado en alrededor
de un 7 8%
y por otro lado la votación de un sector
sobre todo joven de una izquierda que no
se siente representada en la izquierda
correísta y que incluso ya en el
gobierno de rafael correa tuvo serios
problemas fue digamos
perseguida incluso como por ejemplo a
los dirigentes de la unión nacional de
educadores del sindicato de los
profesores
es decir que hay una hay un voto que se
va a expresar por primera vez en estas
elecciones que es un voto joven que
seguramente va a tener una importancia
significativa pero yo yo creo que
en esa votación va a llegar en un tercer
lugar no no sé si pueda disfrutar uno de
los dos primeros lugares si la pregunta
que queda y que seguramente
esta está prevista me adelantó que iba a
pasar con esa votación en la segunda
vuelta
la dejo ahí que no sabemos qué va a
pasar el domingo es cuando se define
esos dos candidatos que pueden pasar a
una eventual segunda vuelta o puede
salir definitivamente un presidente ya
electo a partir del domingo todos los
escenarios son posibles maría para sus
impresiones sobre este candidato
a ver ya q pérez es un personaje de la
política bastante interesante justamente
proviene del origen de un brazo político
del movimiento indígena tradicionalmente
como bien señalaba simón simboliza mucho
de la agenda contemporánea que quizás es
ha sido una de las tantas debilidades de
los otros candidatos del resto por
aglutinar les así lo cierto es un
candidato que utiliza muy bien
el interés por la naturaleza lo defiende
el derecho si tiene una agenda
ambientalista que ha sido ciertamente
constante a lo largo de su vida pública
articula un discurso feminista un
discurso incluyente un discurso de
jóvenes un discurso quizás un poco más
fresco y eso creo que es potente pero no
nos olvidemos que el movimiento indígena
como tal con sus distintos brazos
políticos pachakutik la conaie
ecuarunari también se han ido dividiendo
también fueron golpeados por el fenómeno
del correísmo algunos cooptados la
mayoría perseguidos y también estamos
dejando de lado para esta reflexión lo
que es octubre de 2019 no es cierto la
protesta más sangrienta mal disruptiva
que ha habido en las últimas décadas
con el pretexto de la eliminación del
subsidio de la gasolina pero que en
realidad se ve una clara relación o se
dilucida entre algunos de los líderes
indígenas y el correísmo con unos datos
ciertamente violentos de un gobierno
gran débil que le obliga a echarse para
atrás pero lo importante de esto es ver
que estos líderes históricos o
tradicionales ya no están en la línea de
jacco ps con lo cual el capital político
que pueda tener siempre se va a ver
afectado por esta presencia no ha tenido
la habilidad de no de no desmarcarse del
todo de estos candidatos pero eso
también le pasa factura llamar te ha
mantenido una distancia prudente pero yo
creo que hay un porcentaje del
electorado importante que jamás le
perdonaría el no ser firme en reprochar
a aquellos líderes que si se acercaron
mucho al correísmo y que protagonizaron
estas protestas que que marcaron mucho
en el sentimiento de la sociedad
ecuatoriana sobre todo para llegando al
final del programa ya las conclusiones
maría paz su balance del gobierno de
lenin moreno que ya finaliza
paso por el gobierno ecuatoriano logró
desmarcarse definitivamente el correísmo
usted ha resaltado en varias de sus
intervenciones que fue un gobierno débil
que le faltó un poco de margen de
negociación por ejemplo con estas en
estas protestas le falta un poco de mano
dura en algunas decisiones para tomar
cuál es su opinión
complejísimo poder poder resumirlo
porque el gobierno del presidente moreno
ha tenido varias etapas en términos
generales podemos decir que posibilitó o
generó las garantías para judicial izar
algunos de los casos emblemáticos y
siendo concretos para eliminar por ahora
de la figura política del ex presidente
correa y lograr marcar algunas
divisiones entre los sectores
entre los poderes del estado eso pero
que fue un triunfo para la sociedad creo
que ahora no lo vemos creo que la
historia y el tiempo le dará sin embargo
no se desmarcó del todo de muchas de las
redes propias del correísmo y de la
vieja política ecuatoriana ojo entonces
todos esos aciertos que logró en un
momento dado esos consensos que eran tan
necesarios en la sociedad en este pacto
ciudadano en este contrato social en
ciertamente se han oscurecido con muchos
actos de corrupción y con una muestra de
incapacidad
liderazgo y de dar respuesta en momentos
de crisis y claro si los grandes estados
y los gobiernos más sólidos se pusieron
verdes no tuvieron problemas para
enfrentar la crisis económica y la
crisis de la pandemia perdón peor aún un
gobierno en nuestras condiciones
entonces creo que lo que empezó de mejor
manera termina muy mal
simón su balance de lenin moreno en el
gobierno de ecuador
bueno yo creo que el gobierno del rey ni
moreno fue un gobierno tremendamente
débil sigue siendo muy débiles de los
gobiernos con menos aceptación menos
digamos que con calificación más baja
por parte de la ciudadanía y con menos
margen de acción en el campo político y
en el campo económico es un gobierno que
nunca pudo con saber exactamente con qué
bancada legislativa cortaba los propios
militantes de su de su de su bancada
legislativa cambiaban frecuentemente
votaban en contra del gobierno
en fin en segundo lugar debido a que fue
elegido con el auspicio de rafael correa
el resto de fuerzas políticas tenían
fuerte desconfianza hacia el gobierno
en la ruptura fue incluso calificada
como un tongo como una mentira
durante largo tiempo hasta cuando se
hizo una consulta popular en donde se
plantearon
temas que fueron fundamentales para esa
ruptura recién en el tercer año de
gobierno es cuando las otras fuerzas
políticas se abren de alguna manera a
colaborar con el gobierno y una
colaboración muy típica de la política
ecuatoriana que es una colaboración no
abierta sino siempre por debajo como la
llama un colega unas alianzas fantasmas
y por lo tanto él insisto el margen que
él tuvo para hacer las cosas era mínimo
y esto es lo que nos pone ahora frente a
esta situación de volver a definir si se
continúa con el modelo de rafael correa
o nos vamos hacia otro modelo diferente
que es lo que estaba en juego hace
cuatro años es decir volvimos a la misma
situación de hace cuatro años y tiramos
con unos matices por supuesto pero en
ese aspecto estamos volviendo a la misma
definición maría paz me quedan segundos
para hacerle una última pregunta ecuador
está inaugurando el calendario electoral
en américa latina son los primeros
comicios en el año en este año y vemos
varios países que están en esta misma
situación en volver a darle un poco de
oportunidad socialismo volver a algo más
de centro de derecha o izquierda
ustedes creen que estas elecciones
sentarán precedentes a nivel de américa
latina' maría paz
no estoy segura francamente creo que
términos geopolíticos en la capacidad de
impacto que tiene el ecuador ni siquiera
en la región es determinante ahora
efectivamente creo que estos comicios
tanto aquí como el resto de la región va
a tener una matriz distinta por por el
tema de la pandemia y estoy convencida
que eso marca un camino determinante
igual vemos en el mismo socialismo del
siglo 21 hay de algunas distance algunos
distanciamientos que quizás no son tan
evidentes que son sutiles como lo que
pasó en los últimos días del presidente
fernández desmentir públicamente al
candidato hará dos con el presidente
correa eso no habría pasado entonces
creo que los liderazgos son nuevos son
distintos no me atrevo a decir cuál será
el impacto creo que la capacidad de
incidencia en términos geopolíticos del
ecuador es mínima y creo que más bien
son las fuerzas y no las no lícitas las
que tienen que operan dentro del ecuador
y en la región las que tienen mucha más
capacidad impacto pues se tienen ustedes
las opiniones de marjah para ser vice de
simón pachano en la ciudad de quito
sobre este tema las elecciones
presidenciales en ecuador muchas gracias
a los dos por haber estado con nosotros
y haber compartido sus puntos de vista y
sus opiniones en torno a este tema
ustedes también por favor pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios
de las redes sociales sobre todo si
usted es ecuatoriano viviendo fuera del
país por favor nos interesa conocer su
opinión
gracias por su sintonía sigan con
france24
[Música]